time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get the game now not wait to
your business to successful you have to
own assets that make you money while you
sleep that grow while you sleep and the
challenge for most of America is if this
stuff is not taught in school wanna be
happy
build a life not just the business
hates Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you -
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
become a millionaire
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one become an owner with Tony Robbins
there's a lot of talk about control in
the book what is the one thing that you
want people to understand about control
and you feel out of control they feel
they don't understand the stock market
like what's the one message you want to
you want people to take home around
control I think it's that you have to
become an owner not just a consumer you
have to take a percentage of what you
earn as simplistic as it sounds and
automate it so it comes off the top of
what you earn there's a gentleman used
to work for UPS names Theodore and
theater Robinson was this guy who never
made more than fourteen thousand dollars
a year and yet he retired with seventy
million dollars and gave away thirty
five million was a lot how did he do it
he became an owner his best friend said
to him listen to me the most important
thing in your life is we're gonna put a
12 tax on Eagle is a wealth tax
I made 14 thousand a year goes we're
gonna make you wealthy with this tax
it's not a government taxes tax for
yourself so we're gonna take 20% of what
you earn and put an investment account
let it build up he said I can't afford
that he goes once it's automated you
won't notice that's all he did that made
him seventy million dollars so it's like
people have to understand that no matter
how good you're in business
we all need a second business with no
employees and it takes very little time
something that once you do your homework
should take you you know 15 minutes to
an hour twice a year to rebalance
perhaps what would you tell the startup
entrepreneur who maybe is just getting
started or maybe he still has a
full-time job and it feels like every
dollar that they're making they're just
trying to build their business at the
moment they haven't cashed out yet
should they be invested into the
business should they still be saving
some went to the market what would you
tell that person I think you have to put
something outside your business because
what's the number one rule of investing
that even idiots understand
don't pull all your
eggs in one basket right and what if 90%
of entrepreneurs do because of the
illusion of control they go I'm gonna
put all my money in my business don't
get me wrong it's still a great place
for your money after your time with your
energy but you got to take a piece of
what you earn and you gotta bet on some
other entrepreneurs and get outside
yourself specifically and if you look at
you know somebody like Warren Buffett
I'll sell you you know look he said my
all my wealth as a result of a couple
things some good genes and compound
interest and living in America so if all
you do is get compound interest on your
side the game changes you take a
nineteen year old kid that's got a
little job and you say look I want you
know it sounds like a lot but I want to
put aside three hundred dollars a month
let me show you why three hundred bucks
a month set aside throw it in the market
average market returns been eight
percent spent ten percent of a hundred
years but most recent you know thirty
years eight percent so let's say you get
the average return then it compounds
that kid he starts at nineteen with
three hundred a month can stop at twenty
seven
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in and he's only put in
twenty four twenty eight thousand
dollars but that'll grow to 1.8 million
without putting him in a diamond that's
the power of compounding 28 grand 1.8
million if his best friend starts at 27
when he quits and the desk every single
year all the way to 65 and he puts in
the same three hundred ollars a month
people it's in a hundred forty grand and
at that time he's got four hundred
thousand dollars less money
so it's not the amount of money it's the
amount of time time is your greatest
friend here and if you get in the game
you're gonna win and you need to get the
game now not wait to your business to
success also if you want to have more
motivation and confidence check out my
254 series they're free the link to join
our no description below you've got to
separate the vehicle from the outcome
what is it that's gonna truly fulfill
you what is it that's gonna give you
that extraordinary life the fact that
human beings our strongest drive is the
need to stay consistent with how we
define ourselves what's going to fulfill
you is differently at first and next
you're not gonna learn that from anybody
else you got to find it because success
without fulfillment is the ultimate
failure and rule number two the last one
before our very special bonus clip is
invest with David Bach on the game of
Monopoly you go pass going to get a
paycheck
and if you just go around the properties
and you land on them you pay rent right
and you can't win the game Monopoly
unless you buy one green home then two
green homes and three green islands and
four then a hotel right like you have to
be an owner in the game of Monopoly the
ironic thing is that the game Monopoly
is a great lesson promise for life yeah
you have to own assets that make you
money while you sleep that grow while
you sleep and the challenge for most of
America is that this stuff is not taught
in school my grandmother when she
started at 30 she had nothing and she
used to literally save 50 cents a week
and put it in a coffee camp Wow and at
the end of the year she took that coffee
countdown to a brokerage firm and start
investing in stocks that's what changed
the entire destiny of my family Wow was
that my grandma at 30 with no college
education or he a Gimbels department
store Milwaukee Wisconsin got tired of
being poor there's some people watching
today that are there right there
listening they're watching the serger
listen to us and they're tired of being
poor my grandmother was frustrated and
she came home and said to my grandfather
on her 30th birthday jack this is not
working like and when you're the guy and
you hear that you know like what do you
mean this isn't working and my
grandfather said what's not working and
she said we're broke we have any money
and you know to my grandma's credit she
decided to do something about it and
says she literally brown bagged her
lunch every day she brown bagged her
lunch so she could save that money and
go invest and the way the story turns
out Louis is my grandma thought my first
book smart women finished rich was
dedicated to her and she can become rich
overnight she built wealth over her
lifetime yeah I always say it's decades
not days people who try to get rich
quick stay broke long mm-hmm it's true
like show me those banner ads on how to
get rich quick and I'll show you a way
to stay poor forever right so my
grandmother realize like you you invest
in great American companies and you just
keep investing and you leave it
even you leave it and she helped me buy
my first stock 87 in McDonald's Wow
and that was 7 years old it was like she
taught me she taught me three lessons
about money at 7 that to this day I
still teach which I can share with Corsa
so at 7 we're sitting McDonald's and she
says you know David you can get rich at
McDonald's I looked her I'm like grandma
I'm eating my you know my cheeseburger
and my french fries I have my apple pie
I said we're talking about and she's
like I'm not how am I getting a job here
she's like see those people over there
they're working for what's called
minimum wage and I think back then
minimum wage was like $1 nothing and she
said it's very hard to make a living on
minimum wage she said there's kid people
like you right now like all these people
are coming here and they're eating and
they're spending money that's called a
spender and she said then there's some
people who own this place and owners get
rich then she said you and I love to
play Monopoly at 7:00 that was my thing
I'd go to the ground with her and she
played Monopoly with me and she said I'm
gonna teach you how to play Monopoly for
real and she took me home that day she
opened up the Wall Street Journal she
circled MCD that's the symbol still to
this day from McDonald's and she said
here's how much McDonald's is she put me
in front of a television screen and said
watch the ticker tape she taught me how
to read that ticker tape and she said
just call out the price on MCD that's
the price of McDonald's and she said
tomorrow I'll take you on her brokerage
firm will open up an account you'll
you'll buy one share that stock and then
every time you go there you'll know
you're making money from yourself Wow
that is a WoW right and it's funny
because I'm here in LA with you but I
just went to Disneyland two days ago
with my son he's my son who's 9 and
Disneyland robot Disney I bought is now
that was my sack that was my second
stock that's amazing so like literally
at nine I'm at Disney with Grandma and
I'm like hey Mickey are you guys public
like you know because she taught me to
think as a child like an investor now
I'm doing the same thing with my kids no
my kids don't want to own McDonald's
anyone own Shake Shack rides so my son
owns Shake Shack right down the street
for a new one right my younger son after
Disneyland's like I want to own Disney
his older brother owns Disney it's
doubled he's like well I want my own
Disney my kids own Amazon so you know
they're they're learning like island now
this stuff should be taught in school
today this is the school right like
today what we do is another way to teach
people so but those are simple lessons I
just gave you yeah but that were passed
to me and we just did that in a matter
of minutes now I have a special bonus
clip from Warren Buffett on how to
understand accounting that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go watch
number one how can you become a better
owner number two what's one small step
you can take today to start taking
action and number three where do you
need to make better investment decisions
and if you like this video and promised
you take action after watching it give
me a hash tag believe down the comments
as well we don't just watch videos here
we do something about it
so give me a hash tag believe make that
promise to yourself
and then get to work people ask me what
they should take in business school and
and and or even if they don't go to
business school what they need to know
before getting in business and I tell
them you know you have to you have to
understand accounting it's the language
of it yet it would be it's like being in
a foreign country
without knowing the language if you're
in business and you don't understand the
accounting so it it it you want to get
as comfortable with that as you are with
the English language it it's made me a
lot of money because I I listen to what
raideen had to say fifty three or four
years ago and have been able to
understand what I was seeing on pieces
of paper what that told me about
businesses and the limitations of what
it told me about businesses
if you want to know why poverty is not
an accident and what keeps you broke
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
so thing about why I say suffering
people cringe people that do it that's
the one word whenever I post about it
people cringe